POINTERVIEW TH FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD T
WE.LAMED HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
LO DER STOPPING THE RIOTON JANUN
T CAPITOL WITS SUPPORTERS.
GGED TE
AT THE COUP AND IS STILL
REPEATING THE FICTIOHEL BE INSTO
E BANK
OR JEROO TIFFANY'S AND YOU EALN
FOR THE GOP?OR SAY THAT W
S ANSWLEADER MITCH
NO.
>> YOU SAID DONALDMP'S
SURRECTION WERE ,
CO DERELICTION O.
HOO FROM SAYING   TWO LATER SAYT
IN 202SHOULDN'T BE A FRONT PAGE
HEAD THAT I'LL T
REPUBLAN NOMINEE F
PRESIDENT.
TRP CONTINUES TO LIE ABOUT PART.
JANUARY 6th, CNUPUE ENVELOITTH,
NNAPPROACH ABO TMIDTERMS THAN
GENERAL ELECTI.WITH THEEN HE'
LIKE IS ON THE
LLOTFOHIHI
NOMINEE.ESTIONRE IS
NOMINEHIM IT'S ALL ABOUT JUDGES.
AST.
O DO WITH THJUDICIARY.
SENATOR McEL
TAJY LEADER NLLAN BLOCK
BIING A
REPUBLICAN WINS IN 2024 SO HE N.
HETO TRIANGULATE THI
HI. CLOSEPRUMROM
TRUMP IS MORE POPULA THET
REPUBLAN
>> BY A .
Y RIGHT,HE'S U HIM AS TO AN
EN
AND THIL
>> WE LS WEEK,
LANEW
REPORTING FROM C TTWEEDO. ANFOR.
CONTROHE'SKIHEELECTIONE
S ARE EVEN
AND IN SUBSEQUENT TEXTS
A
INCLUDES THE FAKELECTORS
INCLUDESE PRESIDENT
AUTHORITY TO DWH D SAY?
>> THIS HAA LINE
LOG INTO JUST HAT HA BEEED WITHE
NU LEADING
G AT THE N AROUND NOTT THE FO,
WE'V JR.NOW HAD TEXT MESSAGES FM
WE KNOW IVANKA TRUMPAS
INIGIS ANG AS WE RECENTLY. RE
IT GOES TO SOME
MIEA
I INTERVIEW WIT
S DEFLECTINGMEME OF THE SECURIT
HEAROUND WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WHOSE C T
SA, NOARY 6th
>> I WANT TO SWITCH GEARS IT,
LITTLE BIT HERE. NORESIDENT
TRUMDE ENDORSEMENT IN
THPENNSYLVANIA SENATE CE.
TEN.
R. OZ, GAN
RVD UCATEDTREMENDOUS,
TREMENDOUS CY
IN TELEVN  YOU'R
THAT'S A POLL.
THAT MEANS PEO
HE'S A G
>> IT'S ALL OU
IN THERE AREBER
OF TRUMP AIDES WORKING FOR R
AND TRUMP MADE A DIFFE TUATIOE L
ABOUT CELEBRIT'S WHAT EX.
IDN'T KNOW
ENDORMETHE PRIMN ABOUT A MONTH
THISILISF TH
WATCHED TRUMP EMENT OFCORMICK I.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
ARD FOR
DN'T G I
IS PITTING TRUMP AGAINST  FR VI
McCORMICKT MAR-A-
A HTWINGY ANGRIS O
T.
ENOM, ME
E READE WHICN TW
CONFUUSE IT EMS VERY CLEAR HERN
THE ARSTICOF
FORMER PRESIDENT IS THAT HES PE
HE CAME FROM A TV
BACKND
TNMENT IS A
HUGE FACTOR IN POLITICAL WINS
HERE.
TO PUT IT ON THOSE AROUND HIM
NG AON.
>> OZ DID UM HAD HIM ON HIOWANDO
HEALTH, OR WHATEVER THE ACTUAL
DAILY BEAS AS THBEG  ER ADVIS CT
ADSETE
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER AND TPERSO
WELL, AND THE PRESIDENBEG THIN